The answer is the last two only.
For the roommate problem,
we make a vertex for each individual.
And we add an edge between two vertices
if the two individuals are compatible.
We find a max matching and
matched edges become roommates.
This is a great application
of maximum matching.
But, more likely than not there will
be an odd cycle of compatibility,
meaning that the graph is not bipartite.
This changes the nature of
the problem significantly.
The taxi problem on the other
hand is clearly bipartite.
We model the taxis with
one set of vertices and
the customers with the others.
And we want to find
the minimum total pick up time.
We can imagine having edges between
the taxis and customers finding and
matching here, and
adding up all of these times.
The problem here is
the existence of the costs,
which demand a different solution
from just finding a maximum matching.
Assigning professors to classes
is a bipartite matching problem.
One side of the partition
is the professors, and
the other is the classes, and
we include an edge if the professor
is qualified to teach class.
A maximum matching solution then will
allow us to teach as many classes
as possible.
Hopefully, this will be all of them.
The situation with organ donors and
patients is analogous.
We add an edge if the patient
will accept the organ, and
we match as many organs
to the patient as we can.